hello everyone I am Alexander many of
you know me our program chair and one of
the organizers of Europe Eisen and I
just want to give a short reminder in
one week's time is Europe - in Rimini
and we're going to switch on on desk
race on Monday so if you're thinking
about going to Europe lies on buy your
tickets this weekend
otherwise it will be more expensive if
you're a speaker or an attendee and have
questions come and ask me for anything
I'm here but actually I'm here to
announce PyCon de that's the German
Python conference we're going to be in
cultural this year cos Rho is down here
everybody knows this it's well connected
we're the TGV to Paris and the IC e
train to the rest of Germany it's the
home of the ki T that's one of the best
universities in Germany and it was for
like four decades a major hub for
engineering in Germany probably the best
engineering hub and very happy to have
the conference there on its it will be
at the sent home for cool - on median
and Cal so that's that's a mixture of
museum and media Institute which has
museums exhibitions and we're very happy
that we can have the conference there um
it's the location Kraftwerk actually
chose 1997 for the opening to have their
first concert I think in more than 10-15
years in Germany so he all the facts the
conference is end of October um the CFP
is open and we will be very data heavy
in cultural and one way oh yeah okay
katharyne is also one of the organizers
well you know everybody knows Kathryn
you know just in time
thank you yeah the CD is open it will be
quite data heavy arm
in a tech cup city so we will have many
PI data talks there arm we're also happy
if you want to submit a talk early birds
tickets are still available so we're
going to switch soon on then you can
find more information on our website or
you can ask me at a social event and
yeah that's it thank you yeah has
anybody
quick question question one good
question what you are always online
super next speaker dr. do one piece on
that this will be fun good
awesome
hi everyone my name is Stefan and I'm
here today to warn you of a troubling
development in Python Python is turning
into Java so as we all know Python is
the greatest language in the world and
we're very used we're very used to the
fact that other languages learn from us
we're great and even go which has been
getting a bit more attention lately is
really just a compiled Python and don't
even get me started about JavaScript
JavaScript is imitating Python so much
that it's getting a bit awkward
generators for example JavaScript took
them made them a bit worse by requiring
that little asterisk and the function
keyword but still they're all idea so
you're welcome Eggman script Y space
indentation you're welcome CoffeeScript
I guess ok whitespace annotation is a
bit more of a disputed issue but still
Titan is great so let me highlight some
of the recent things that has been
making the way into a Python 3 what on
earth is this so we've got an enum there
we used to be fine without enums do we
really need in ohms then there's
something about a single dispatch you
know that calls the same function
depending on the type of the argument
and then finally is that a type
annotation I see in the function
signature that smelled like coffee to me
so let's deconstruct everything that's
wrong with this piece of code bit by bit
and I hope you notice the sarcasm tack
in the beginning enum I mean what was
wrong with just passing strings around
and testing for string equality or at
least you know making module level
variables and counting up one two three
four five manually that worked fine
enums well if you're if you're honest
they're a little bit nicer you can
actually list all the things that are in
the numeration and somehow that first
kind of thing in the enum is one but
also it's smart enough to know that it's
not one it's it's a different thing so
okay maybe enums are a little bit
smarter than just you know counting
passing names for integers around but I
think we all agree that pythons of
dictionaries and you should put all your
data in dictionaries right
I mean classes are dictionaries of the
the dictionaries and much of the Python
standard library actually operates on
dictionaries or mapping types and
general argument parts or config parser
if you've got a little function here
that just summarizes the hotel you
should just put your data in a
dictionary and well actually one thing
though is that there's a typo in that
code it says print hotel reviews Konitz
which I'm sure you notice and also what
else is in hotel anyways it's a
dictionary what is in there well it's
easy you just add a debugger step and
look inside Shirley Python would never
look like this because that ugly and
looks like Java actually some of you
might know that this is actually valid
Python 3.6 syntax and even though it's
totally totally unnecessary once you
actually start using it it does turn out
to be nice so this is a screenshot from
my PI charm I have that class up there
I'm annotating my hotel parameter to be
off that type pycharm notices that
reviews Kona is actually not a member of
that class and even though I'm in one of
those new Python 3:6 format strings
there's autocomplete that tells me hey
there's a score that's probably what you
want to print all right this actually
isn't all that bad but thing of this
stretch is that really necessary
the single dispatch made it into this
Python standard library in 3/4 or
something and it's about calling generic
functions depending on the type of the
first argument again the smells smells
so much like coffee and what you can see
here is that there's a generic function
up there that's kind of a fallback and
then if you want a different version of
the same function to be call depending
on the type of the first thing and here
I'm referring to the things enum from
before I can do that and notice down
there I'm calling handle things kind of
thing imma calling handle things Tyson
just calls that thing so I'm doing stuff
depending on the type weren't we doing
duck type duck typing before what what
is wrong with this picture that's been
working for years right actually so duck
typing is evolving in the Python
language a little bit and instead of you
know just believing everything that
quacks you actually believe
duck that it tells you to be a duck it's
still duck typing in a way but this is
where the sarcasm ends I really really
like all these new features that Python
3 recent versions are adding in wave
Python 3 is growing up growing up
together with us
these features are optional but they're
very useful for code that is read more
often than written and that's most code
really a large project so you should all
use the latest Python 3 thank you
[Applause]
nope
just minutes this is get out
you
okay good so we are the conference and
maybe you like conferences maybe like
another conference therefore would like
to talk about yours I PI your sci-fi has
a university this year so we have a
tenth edition 10th edition of our
European conference on pison in science
it will be an element in Germany it's
just a few kilometers south of here so
you can take a train to London at the
University and it will be soon it will
be the end of August so instead in the
summer so we have about less than a week
of conference your sci-fi is it
different than PI data it's a general
pison conference is very cross
dissimilarity so a lot of people from
different backgrounds in science
starting from aquaculture to geology are
there and they present their research
their core contributions is extended
till tomorrow so if you would like to
present a talk a poster or a tutorial at
this conference you need to hurry up
because we only have time till tomorrow
to submit registrations also open a few
important dates so the extended deadline
for the talks is tomorrow and the early
registration still open for a while and
then we have two days of tutorials
that's very nice very interesting
because half of the conference
essentially is tutorials the other half
are two days is talks and then we have
sprints if you would like to sprint us
on on some scientific Python project
like numpy or Syfy or something and us
other projects then you can take part in
Spain to organize your own sprint and
the prices are pretty reasonable if you
see here this is the prices for the
tutorials so that early abroad is still
valid and also in the same prices are
available for the conference so you can
either register for either one or both
of them so if you're interested in pints
and science you shouldn't this
opportunity to come to your site by in
along and in less than two months thank
you very much
[Applause]
yeah thank you for this brief
introduction
I'm Jana stearin and I will talk about
screening breast cancer with biotin if
at any point in the talk it isn't really
clear what it has to do with biotin I'll
just be patient
things will get clearer near the end so
first some context in the Dutch context
we have a screening program for breast
cancer and all ladies between 50 and 75
are full interiorly come every two years
to have a screening mammogram so it's
really successful it saves about 850
lives per year and our participation has
to risk all that has the risk of dying
from breast cancer where there are some
some challenges there is that in a
screening setting most images are
negative
there are lots of images - that's the
other there's really high screening
volume so radiologists have little time
to screen each image so this creates
lots of opportunities for machine
learning first of all this is a
mammogram well a machine so you compress
the breast so we have low radiation dose
apparently it's really painful so you
want to do this as quick as possible of
course we want to do this with a
computer and here I just took an image
of DCIS with dr. carcinoma in situ in
situ and the signs of this type of
cancer or all kinds of are these small
dots
you also have just normal tumors which
are really large messes in the image and
right now how we do this with machine
learning it's so basically we start with
the screening mammogram which is an
x-ray image we have a candidate feature
extraction that extracts some sexy
candidates and then we use a random
forest classifier on these these
candidates this is the classical way to
do it and on the Left image the first
stage in the pipeline creates lots of
candidate regions which are then
classified using neural network and as
you can see in the next image right now
we are almost doing as well as a
radiologist so in the end if we would be
able to use this if we use a system in a
screening setting we could filter out
many of the negatives and reduce the
amount of images a radiologist has to
screen we have many other so as I said
in one of the previous slides in DCIS
you want to detect the small dots and
these are called calcifications and at
least are arg recent models with neural
networks outperform the classical models
which have been developed for the last
20 years and this is from 2060 one more
thing and if you like medical imaging
and you would like to work in deep
learning on medical imaging please check
out our vacancies we have a lot of
postdoc and PhD positions available
[Applause]
thank you very much now we need about
helping women notice by Conchita too
[Applause]
he's we're not quite there yet if the
next person yes I know about the
difficulty
[Applause]
okay so my name is Sachin and I'll be
working on future tutorials on deep
learning and my company so the aim was
to get people up and up and running on
deep learning as fast as possible and
make it practical right and just keep in
mind that these people they have a very
minimum experience in machine learning
so I want to get them started on doing
even the advanced ones as fast as we can
so if you could just go to this link and
just check it out to begin with so it's
mainly a github page right now so what I
want to do is imitate something like
nerd school and by the way if I still
haven't registered this this name it's
it's available so please don't register
it so moving on so like I said the aim
was to make it easier minimize the
required amount of mathematics such a
need because especially these days you
don't need that much mathematics to get
started on deep learning it's only a few
lines make it practical so that you can
run it on laptops right
yes GPUs can come later on the whole
point again is to get them up and
running so that they can do it later on
and open sources so I do want you to if
you could contribute to this be set of
tutorials so that yeah it could be
better so what I have is is these bunch
of lessons so so far I've only got two
lessons but just to give you a taste of
what I have so so I'm mainly using
carers to do this right so over here you
can see this it's only what five or six
months of code to get a deep neural net
running and I think think in this case
it was a sentiment analysis problem but
the main point is you only need a few
lines of code to do this deep learning
these days
I've gone on to do so the latest thing
that I've done so far is convolutional
nets so one thing that that's really
missing I guess is there's not enough
text I suppose so what I tend to do is
this there's generally a youtube link in
most of these tutorials not that one but
okay anyway so some of the stores have a
youtube video on at the top and I try to
try to make sure that these are that the
takeaways and I try to document that
okay like by the end of this tutorial
you shouldn't you should know these
terms so just just quickly going through
a convolutional net that that's a
convolution but as far as the code goes
which is really what I'm trying to get
across
again it's five or six lines of code
it's quickly running down to this one
this this is CFR ten data set so we have
this about there's ten classes that I
had to classify and that 10,000 images
for this and it ran in less than in less
than 10 minutes and the accuracy was
about 50% now that's not that great but
considering its ten classes
that's actually pretty decent for for
ten minutes of training so just right
down to the bottom
okay so so these are the some classes
that are predicted so it classified but
very correctly horse is fine and when it
came to dog as a cat I don't know if I
chew all of classifies as a dog but you
know there's this additional question I
guess yeah so anyway the the point of
this talk is if you can contribute
contributors github repo so it may like
Ari will probably need a bit more help
in the documentation more than anything
because I've really folks maybe a bit
too much on the the code rather than
actual text writing stuff in because I
do generally do a YouTube video with
this which I've attached to most of the
most of the tutorials and but not
everyone so so that's that's pretty much
it so what yeah if you have any
questions come talk to me afterwards
thank
[Applause]
well I can lightly questions on me yes
yep so sorry I missed that
oh don't don't write on that right so
[Applause]
what is negative the presentation of
medical concepts
[Applause]
hello everyone so this is going to seem
like a shameless plug compared to all
the lightning talks that we've seen so
far but I want to talk to you about some
of the work that I'm doing at Babylon
Health which is a health care company
based in London I'm a part of the
machine learning and NLP team there and
I'll talk to you about distributed
representations of medical hub concepts
so surely you've heard of work to Veck
today at least five times but I'll take
the liberty to take you back to the
basics of what it is and why we're using
it so essentially we're using it because
it's a better universal representation
of words better than what we had before
something that we handcrafted ourselves
and we can plug it very easily and in
different machine learning models across
different platforms and it's it's much
more Universal than we have what we had
before so why do we really care about
this in Babylon
our current dispatcher model the thing
that talks to the to the patients and
decides what to do with them is based on
a deep learning model that uses text
embeddings but this is a fairly simple
task we want to do more complicated
things and we want to extract things we
want to be more flexible and matching in
our information extraction tasks so we
need something better than that so let's
start from the basics real start from
real basics so you should know a word by
the company keeps that's what John first
said basically / phrasing so and
Wittgenstein and you can see it
everybody in the room probably knows
what the word is missing right
if you don't maybe you shouldn't be at
this conference so if we can tell the
word but it bites context then we can
compare context to make to define
similarity between words and if we can
do that then maybe we can build models
for each of the word and then for each
word and then compare those instead of
comparing contexts or comparing words
and that's what word Tyvek does it takes
it builds a dummy task which guesses if
the word is the word fox is there or not
if it based on the context and then
build the model and the model is
essentially the word fox in our new
model space so essentially this model is
a very ugly vector of floats oh okay
sorry about that ah which we can
represent nicely in the two two
dimensions that sort of look like this
this is generated based on Google uses
corpus and this this is sort of useful
but one more useful thing that we are
interested is the compositionality
property of the factors we can we can do
certain operations with these vectors
which result into something I don't know
how many people are aware of what this
is okay so basically but not everybody
so so basically we we are able to take
the meaning of to take the the vector
for King subtract the vector for his
gender so subtract man and essentially
get a vector for a genderless royal and
then add
another gender woman and get the vector
for free queen and why is this useful
this proves that we can manipulate
vectors and the results are actually
meaningful they're not just random
things there there is a space that
operates in Europe maybe not all the
operations that we can think of work but
some of them do so shall we know a
disease by the company keys is the
question that we are pondering at
Babylon and the answer is yes but not
the company words so the reason for that
is we want to encode medical knowledge
not meaning so not everything in
medicine is expressed in text and you
can't like just infers all all of the
medicine from the older text that exists
even if you take all the text there's
just not some things are not encoded in
distribution so what we did is we turn
into furniture medical ontology and
which is a basically a very very big
graph with a lot of connections in it
and we generated a lot of random walks
which are kind of like sentences when
you think about it there are sentences
of medical concepts and sorry I 30
seconds well that's actually the last
slide
maybe so the result is a similar space
and you can do similar operations with
vectors which kind of work we don't know
what we're going to do with that yet we
are still to figure out how to test it
how good it is so thank you and never
mind for exit we're hiring
[Applause]
but thank you next we'll have just a
recognition with deep learning
hi so just give us 30 seconds to set up
so first things first we've decided to
provoke the demo gods today so we're
going to show you a demo of our
real-time gesture recognition system we
have absolutely no idea whether it's
going to work on this stage in these
lighting conditions and so on
[Applause]
all right
so the first hurdle connecting the
laptop to the to the Beamer has worked
alright so my name is valentin valentin
hannah and this is Yoanna matter Gingka
and we're employees at twenty billion
neurons one of the sponsors the lanyard
sponsor of this conference and over the
last couple of months we've built a
gesture recognition system using deep
learning that's works in real-time
basically what you can see here is a
simple screen and a bunch of classes so
I'm not sure how well you can read them
but some of these classes are for
example stop sign so maybe you could do
the stop sign ooh demo God's not in our
favor
so as you can see building any kind of
deep learning system that is invariance
is the difficult task maybe you can
continue to do other things
all right we'll fiddle it with it a
little bit more I'll tell you a few
details about the system so basically we
crowd acted about 120,000 videos on
Amazon Mechanical Turk of basically
people just sitting in front of their
webcam and performing certain kinds of
gestures with that we predefined so in
total it was I think 27 gestures that we
predefined and yeah basically we got
lots and lots of people all across the
globe of various different nationalities
genders skin colors and so on and so
forth to essentially record these videos
and we then trained a deep learning
model using a whole load of 3d
convolution so it's actually quite
expensive to really capture the temporal
aspects of the videos what should we do
I want to try it in front of the white
wall could one of you hold the laptop
potentially so it does actually work I
you it does work
[Applause]
yeah it keeps the air so that's drumming
fingers let's see what it says about the
room
so there you go so yeah that's the end
of our presentation we're going to be
around we're probably going to get a
test somewhere maybe later on or maybe
tomorrow and then we'll try it again and
yes we are certain that it worked and in
fact a couple of weeks ago our CTO did
the demonstration it just worked
perfectly I'm very surprised why it's
not working today
thank you very much
[Applause]
now we'll have now we'll have Catalina
will tell us about how to win the Nobel
Prize and you can start speaking since I
mean in five minutes or less
you can subsequent I'll turn this on
thank you
No
good evening my name is Catherine I'm
from Romania and working at outer leaves
I'm doing machine learning but I will
not speak this evening about the
self-driving car but more about myself
and the one minute introduction story
starts from when I was a little child
and I heard something about Nobel Prizes
in literature and the pack of there are
some some big things and I said to
myself okay I want to get one after that
I completely forgot about one thing
wanted to to win a Nobel Prize in
Literature because I wanted to become an
astronaut than a scuba diver than an
archaeologist and many many others and I
remember about these sort of things only
recently when Bob Dylan won the Nobel
Prize in Literature as I said okay so
probably I I missed the first thinking
in writing in in winning a Nobel Prize
which is writing literature and okay yes
okay so since I lost start I downloaded
all Bob Dylan's lyrics and I trained the
recurrent neural network and lsdm type
of neural network actually so it's a
sequence to sequence type of network
it it maps sequence of a given length of
characters on the shifted sequence with
one curve character one more character
and like this it's able to predict
character by character the next one and
I started with an embedding layer I've
done this in chaos I will show you bits
of a code in the last minute probably
and then to lsdm layers one fitting into
another but some of the results if we
can scroll down Oh some of the lyrics
are so that I think about a highway I
was hi where my heart where my heart is
ready and like that are are well
reasonably poetic and I have also
experimented a hybrid person between Bob
Dylan and Marilyn Manson and if I forgot
to mention that so I gave for the
prediction part I gave the string knock
knock knockin on heaven's door and slide
the algorithm continue let a character
by character and the hybrid is yes again
pretty poetic so knock knock knockin on
heaven's looking for pain
and voila yes probably more or less out
of time but if you go to github and yeah
you can see the network itself is kind
of Jeremy Howard styles of lsdm networks
so yeah let's say thank you
[Applause]